questi upgrade di cappelli che faccio si
vede che pian piano con l'età sto
maturando per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video sono vari generi sono
pikachu in realtà non sono famiglie non
eravate accorti e birbantelli siamo dati
ragazzi sulle piste questa volta ragazzi
troviamo in prima posizione steelhead e
coin che non ho ben capito perché è un
field coin dovrebbe essere primo visto
che non fanno cagare tutti chi è che
mette prima sta merda però dovete stare
calmi tutti dovete stare calmi perché ce
l'hai con la mia gamba cosa ti ha fatto
se smi piatto il poco però il pogo non
lo colpisce nessuno dei problemi già i
fermi in attesa che ci voglio provare
notte sono vuoi capire veramente chi è
la gente che vota asti livelli al
massimo perché non ho parole
sicuramente gente più fortunata di me
ragazzi fatemi riuscirci no vabbè non ci
credo staccati [ __ ] staccati
trascinati bravo zio perfetto ce la
farai con l'ultimo ce la farai sei
veloce se lo fossimo
non si vuole lanciare si tiene al
pavimento perché credo che ci fosse un
motivo però non non so se è così chiaro
allora veniva un attimo se riesco a
passare in quel modo tranquillo vai
senza di me separabili come compagni
porca [ __ ] ancora porca eva o perché
arrivare sempre alla fine così non puoi
leggere tipo una ragione in più frate
perfetto perfetto con la testa vale se
non fosse stato per il fatto che devo
prendere per forza una moneta alla fine
magari
non sono neanche morto con l'ultimo c'è
qualcuno quanta pagine quanto sexy
no non è gesù cristo che sta passando
sopra i sogni risposto la la luce bene
con perfetto così che non ingombra hoc
bene io sì che so fare lo youtube
impulsivo swing che c'è in poteva allora
sirop swing ha fatto l'unione tra io mi
metto a fare i segni mentre c'è il
livello che va avanti
sono un [ __ ] genio dicevano unito un
impossible rock swing
ma veramente come cazzo fatto vincere
nove il primo tentativo non ci credo mai
nella vita
bobo fight lei poco fa luke ty bravo
complimenti perché c'è una pila di merda
per terra una pila di haters pila di
haider morto anche uno shock che me lo
deve trascinare invece no
se vi si sia poi tagliati dai cazzo
nonno per favor grazie di tutto ciò la
mannaia anche dietro adesso sono
diventato un'arma letale qualche roba
un'arma letale che si ammazzano sola
niente ma le parti carica la botta
potente violenta ora che carica la botta
potente nicchia come leonati tutti
fratello mio deve essere
no no maya posso fissarti i piedi per il
resto della mia vita quanto è difficile
sto di vecchi lo sapevo sono vivo c'è
una spada nel culo può essere molto
violenta guardali quasi amici famiglia
trampolino bravo non perfetto sentitevi
sono rotto il cazzo basta suo livello di
merda lights out l'aisla il salto vuol
dire che ti devi togliere dal calcio
perfetto
l'aitante tipo ah ok ma non era un film
lights out trade tweakie9 la voce fatto
questo una volta abbiamo saranno dal non
so parlare vediamo saranno aggiornato
tipo lightswitch dose work dem si stupì
e non ho fatto in tempo a leggere perché
tua madre [ __ ] quindi ok
salve questo è quello di find that
freddy's questa è ma comunque non mi
ricordo sarà uguale a livello che ho già
fatto tempo fa però mi sembra empty mag
textbox è molto simile comunque indovina
chi è tornato indovina chi viene a cena
speriamo non sia giovanni rana questa è
una school bag
ma più non si rompono lisa in nicchie
che ha rotto il cazzo lights out due
ancora seguito la stanza a letto di mio
fratello va bene un vaso appena preso
vita ma facciamo finta di niente
buongiorno c'era un ombra che aveva
mangiato da mcdonald poco fa style
vecchio del living room ok sto suonando
la sveglia sta per esplodere una bomba
spiegano don't let york times over a un
mio
che cosa vuol dire over all
non lo so però sto rumore mi fa
veramente paura frigo dove la nutella ok
acqua a quanto pare la nutella me la
devo preparare però non so se ho il
tempo di farlo ingredienti allora che
perfetta the passato a samara di the
ring ma facciamo finta di niente toaster
ragazzi dove cazzo devo andarmi se devo
tornare indietro a dove certi perché
muoiono i fiori le cose bonsai three va
bene ma poi non c'era la stanza da letto
di mio fratello
ok basta con gli animatronics basta co
ste cosa andiamo avanti ma era giusto
col cazzo es andavo su non potevo andare
su che almeno un giorno me negli inferi
porcaccia e valenza bene questo vino
invecchiato 800 anni vero ragazzi salve
senta lei non ha un bell'aspetto
proponendo posso offrirle questa candela
omaggio se papà tutta la candela se
pappato anche me secondo me prova bene
grazie bel livello mi è piaciuto adesso
vado a dormire subito cinque minuti won
the line o dalla la resa pesante del
daily line ok ok mica succhia temi le
palle only for ninja se come farmi io
sono fa vige vale anche di più dei ninja
vedi come valgo di più di ninja sicoli
cinesi alla fermerà più
ok cazzo suo non ai piedi ma chi se
frega di piedi puzzano
mica che vittoria che macchia bisogno
dei piedi quando hai un bene fortissimo
sisters location questo non è farina del
freddo è la puntata di halloween questa
è vero
capello la facciamo le puntate tutte
horror l'ho capito adesso cos'è sta roba
è mica facile the freddy's proprio va
bene proprio files on things staying va
bene zio click day o più sbattermi
chiama fai da tè freddi sisters location
è identico meno male che almeno non mi
devo continuare quel gioco di merda ok
mi fate entrare nel condotto cosa devo
fare bene ma vabbè ragazzi ha fatto un
gol bellissimo procede alla tua destra
entra nell'auditorium va bene non ho
capito un caso che non è più difficile
questo che fa in altre di scolo vero
sono convinto e rega che cazzo fa a
perfetto all'auditorio una l'auditorium
è proprio quella fai le tesi non vedo
niente bene ciò anche l'ansia addosso
fantastico c'è una macchia di sangue che
forse non devo toccare ma io la toccherò
lo so già
non la vedo più ma funziona come fai
perché allora sisters location dove
andare piano sono mi mangiava la
famiglia invece qua in teoria prime e
trombi ce l'ho fatta salve e chi cazzo è
questo assisterlo che ci è finito al
gaver avis todi verte è arrivato al
punto cruciale finisce così [ __ ]
vedeva bene lo stesso mi sono contento
rampage che cosa cazzo appena visto
ragazzi perché c'è un offesa che tiene
una pistola perché c'è una pistola che è
tenuta in mano da un obeso
no ma la fisica in questo gioco conta
tantissimo ed shot questo sta pulendo la
macchina che cazzo pulisci brutto idiota
bellissimo che poi l'arma mira due metri
sopra gross paro e lo colpisce va bene
posso sparare anche l'orologio è mista
in culo no stato quando sparo salto ma
poi non sta cagando sta cagando sto
povero cristo perché lori ucciderlo
questa pistola è veramente fake
devo andare avanti mi fai andare avanti
per farlo devo torna indietro torniamo
indietro a salve un giorno quello e
uomini e donne e meriteresti di peggio
se mentre nell'altra che mi sembrava
molto molto accogliente avete presente
quando la vostra ragazza ci mette
800.000 anni a scegliere il vestito
io sì c'è adesso ce lo presenta anche ma
basta non stai mangiando vegano
confronto impedimenti ancora più pelato
[Musica]
c'è questo lo devo votare sei stelle ma
dai una stella in più finale vibrante
non te lo aspetteresti mai manco black
mirror fantastico no stupendo co.in
trampolino il topolino della coin di
hunger games a nova le monete scusa non
avevo capito se ma che palle non ha
senso non so fare su e giù belli questi
livelli dove deve sfoggiare la mia
abilità videoludica mi emozionano
proprio fare lo youtuber è un lavoro
sempre più difficile degli ultimi tempi
ragazzi non me lo so descrivere
[Musica]
che bello questo fazzoletto che bello
potrà ammirarlo per ora questo
fazzoletto perfetto sono fatta ragazzi
ci ho messo una vita e mezza a fare sta
roba ma va bene è stato impegnativo
tantissimo foto il flip 4k battlefield
4k guarda film più 4 che anche vabbè ma
che culo
lo so che tipo di mollare i pali e lo so
che hai questa esigenza però dovresti
andare nel traguardo che sta qua sotto
bravino devia lunga
perfetto di horror burke ma basta con i
veli difendete freddi che palle college
o giorgio howling l'ho detto 8 come se
fosse english ma non è hingis primo
quindi devo beh siamo partiti bene sono
già incastrato in partenza bella lei
fatemi trovare tutti gli otto giovani
ngf prima che mischiarci magari col
salve sono nell'immondizia devo solo
prendere questo grazie gentilissimo
dovrei salire sulla casa se non posso
andare oltre perfetto grazie
ok buongiorno è touch i tetti che tingu
problema se tinu problema mi si dice lo
risolviamo in napoletano cazzo ne so
idonei de merda no aspetta altro non è
che ti ho insultato me devi aggredì ed è
vista calmo belluzzi voi facciamo fi
bravo non era difficile cliccare su un
cazzo di pezzi di carta i bidoni sono
pure brutti al cazzo
però pensavo mi aggredisce il bidone è
meglio così ci siamo sul disegno perfect
testa di culo di un nonno ciak noi devo
andare spiega mi
grazie di avermi indicato la via go back
and back dove spiega mi sono già visto
tutto dietro la [ __ ] eva beh mica
[Applauso]
salve salvi anche a lei a vedremo se lo
prende lo pregano prende se torna
indietro al tizio forse riesco ancora a
cliccare sui dipinti sui siti bene sarò
scherzi niente non c'è vero ci ho
provato ragazzo si è stato alquanto
[Musica]
bevere càsoli spero che video vi sia
piaciuto che un primo episodio di api e
questo un po più halloween
sì più o meno di finale soprattutto cosa
il suo bisogno del momento è un mi piace
andiamocene di facebook e come video
totale descrizione che si rischia che ci
vediamo il prossimo video bene ragazzi